first you're going to want to go in
airbrush the [ __ ] out of that
skinny little waist thicker hips thicker
thighs dude
phone editing software that's we're
going to fix the tan a little bit get
rid of that
hey everyone thanks so much for checking
out this new series today's episode is
brought to you by manscaped
so here's evan with some details boom
this is
the lawn mower 3.0 it is the pinnacle of
mail grooming
and the best thing there's an led light
see that
so if you're shaving in the dark or
navigating any hard drive areas you can
always
see the path and when you order it with
the perfect package 3.0 you
also get ball deodorant and ball toner
i'm learning so many things
and for a limited time subscribers get
not one but two
free gifts there's the shed travel bag
and
the patented high performance reduced
chafing
manscaped boxer briefs go to
manscape.com
jubilee for free international shipping
and 20
off when you order the perfect package
3.0
hope you guys enjoy the episode we'll
see you next time
bye good luck with your balls
something that's keeping a lot of us
distracted these days is watching tick
tock but what we see on the app and how
we perceive it depends on who we are so
we invited strangers from across the
country and around the world
to all react to the same tick tocks so
we can explore
how opposites react
oh [ __ ] sorry sorry editor
sorry what's up my fellow jubilees
probably shouldn't say that okay there
are many different sides to tick-tock
but there's definitely a side
where it really sexualizes like my
gender
a lot of tick tocks portray males is
like the sexy
aha type um i don't know what to expect
i'm just excited to be here even though
i'm here virtually but
like still
the end laugh emoji life emoji so my
boyfriend knows nothing about tampons
right so i'm gonna ask him
i don't know anything about tampons
super tampon and i'm going to say that
it's a lime where it's
super tap on you'll see i have to grab
some concealer can you get me
um a 16 pack of the lime
tampons please lime not the lemon the
lime
okay tampons don't need to be flavored
because
[Music]
you know what i said she wants
i have no idea what i'm doing she said
not
lemon just check to make sure but smell
them smell them smell them
yeah you can't this is a scent
that's lime why are you smelling tampons
that's so weird
she said her boyfriend for failure he
did him dirty on that one though you
cannot deny
he did him dirty because i hate buying
my own products
and i hate when you go up to the cash
register and then you see that it's a
male
that's like checking you out and you're
like oh no oh god oh god oh god
like i know this is normal but oh god oh
no he's gonna see that i got the super
so no
like oh my goodness gracious
[Music]
every boy be like okay let's see every
boy be like what
[Music]
oh that looks so cute
yeah yeah
that's it that's not what every boy be
like that's kind of cringe
it just doesn't make me feel any emotion
it's not funny
sad exciting it's just nothing
it's just the stereotype of like ah cute
guys
great facial features aesthetic lighting
that's
all he's just feeling himself everyone
needs a moment like that everyone needs
to make a tick flop like that
whether they post it or not i'm here for
that
[Music]
this is the battle between boys and
girls what hurts worse getting kicked in
the balls or giving birth
to all the females about this it's just
like
facts okay so i did a little bit of
research and it says a human can
withstand up to 45
del units of pain when a woman is giving
birth they feel up to 57
units of pain but you want to know us
guys go through and get kicked in the
balls when us guys get kicked in the
balls it is 9 000
units of pain we are on the ground about
to throw up i don't care if you guys are
in the hospital for a day to
two days i don't care we feel up to nine
thousand billion is a pain you guys feel
like scientific birth is a whole process
period exclamation mark oh no
can't tell if that's sarcastic or it has
to be sarcasm right
i've actually seen that like pain rating
scale before and i've
told some of my female friends about it
and they do not believe me they refuse
to believe it
first of all labor is like a lot of
hours consecutively you're like
essentially being kicked in the balls
over and over and over for hours giving
back you can legitimately die from
you can't die if you can't keep the ball
you can get your testicles removed which
i've had stories of
they'll never understand the pain of
being kicked through the balls
when your boyfriend doesn't shave his
legs
oh wait i'm boyfriend
you don't need to shape for anyone
that's all i have to say about that
i just see two words woman and orgasm
this is gonna be controversial
[Music]
maybe a long trace isn't it i knew it
oh [ __ ] fake it
that's funny i'm a good christian boy so
i have no idea what that's talking about
you know
you know what that one that one speaks
for itself i'm not gonna go into detail
about that one you you saw what happened
you saw what happened
according to body labs this is what the
average male body looks like there's no
genitalia
i'm going to visualize one trust um
i like when they left i'll be honest
when they're burned
there because i actually have attracted
to it yes i work when their exercise
let's go 12 hours to 12 hours
let's go for that inverted trunk
everyone likes tall dudes
let's go with like 200 pounds
boys if you look like this please hit me
up
oh my gosh her boyfriend is super long
he's like kevin durant i feel like
there's a big double standard with how
like obviously this is a joke but if
there's a guy and he's talking about how
hot
megan fox is like he's objectified her
but when a woman
talks about how hot taylor lautner is
it's okay like i
uh okay
what girls think about ooh oh my god
he's
so cute am i putting too much weight on
him
is my head too heavy i have socks i'm
probably hurting his arm with my
watermelon head girls actually say that
okay so i definitely have lebron on my
team steph curry
kawhi leonard james harden probably
anthony davis oh yeah that'd be a killer
starting point
that's true i mean yeah that's
definitely me every time i think
we girls overthink a lot we think oh
our boys talk like thinking about
cheating on us and all that and they
just be thinking about crap like this
you know
i think this is not completely true guys
can also think of the things that the
girl was thinking like oh am i
holding her hand the right way am i
hugging her too strong or should i kind
of not hug too strong
i kind of feel in some of these videos
they're giving the guys like a simple
mindedness
come on if you're a guy and like a girl
is like leaning on your shoulder you're
not thinking about basketball lineups
come on now
please listen my boyfriend didn't know 3
million likes
it's got to be good how do you pee with
the pad on
how you can with you have to take it off
but first
obviously how how do you pee with the
paddle you just pee in the pad and just
let it sit in your vagina
and you totally have to take it off am i
wrong
duh what are you talking about
where else would you put a pad where
would you put it on there you don't put
a pad on your vagina
what oh it's not actually on your vagina
no it's on your underwear like on the
inside of your underwear
yeah so does it just absorb the blood or
what
yeah we gotta pay attention to health
class come on down i'm shocked
like i'm speech like no yeah i knew that
why
why was i confused in the beginning
maybe we need to ask more questions
educate ourselves
expose myself for this don't let it flop
all right first you're going to want to
go in airbrush the [ __ ] out of that
skinny little waist thicker hips thicker
thighs boom
slim thick now we're going to fix that
tan a little bit get rid of that little
pimp on the top boom go on
now our railings are crooked as [ __ ] so
we're going to oh
wow here
get rid of the crooked railings and
instead
we're going to grab a new background of
the original photo
with the straight railings line it up
now there's going to be some overlap
because you were fat before so now
you're going to erase that overlapping
excuse me just going to trace over it
boom gone race a little bit that's left
keep going
oh my god dude i didn't solve it
we're gonna get rid of that watermark
they left us
let me be honest like seeing
these types of women in media is what
makes women just hate their bodies
right like i haven't worn a bikini in
like six years because i just don't feel
comfortable especially when i see images
like this of like
people who just look photoshopped makes
you imagine how many
people not only put filters on but make
changes to your body to your face and
all that and what we're putting out
there is like this
perfect image of what we want to look
like but not the reality i'm guilty of
doing this too though
it's weird because i think a lot of
times i try to justify it for myself and
say
oh pimples and acne are temporary so
it's okay if i
photoshop them out and make myself look
better because that's like something i'm
insecure about
i get that and i relate
i guess one could argue that some of
them promote
uh stereotypes about you know the gender
binary
as long as you know that it's okay that
you don't have to fit into that
then it's fine to make you know fun
jokes if you watch tick tock not only
for entertainment purposes but if you
watch it with that
lens questioning yourself like am i
reinforcing this gender stereotype and
the type of content that i create and
the things that i do
then i do think there's a lot to learn
and and yeah you can get a lot of
out of it thank you guys for checking
out this new series we
hope you enjoyed it let us know what
topics you would like to see
in another episode of this show
or if you even want us to make new
episodes of this show but thank you for
watching we hope you're staying safe
and we'll see you next time
[Music]